ça vous a manqué oui beaucoup si vous
emmenez nature qui vous a manqué le plus
ou moins le moins qui vous a manqué mois
avec la vérité maintenant on voit ses
bassines allez-y moi je suis août égarés
et mal moi manqué mais que j'aime
beaucoup ça ne me dit rien c'est agathe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parti alors c'est vrai parce qu'il ya eu
un truc dingue at on dit tout vous avez
sms ce week-end un petit week-end elle a
dit tout le monde devrait vous manquer
tout si vous n'avez pas mis le hashtag
nitoo matthieu delormeau delà de ouaga
pas là pour pourquoi bah en fait j'ai
commencé à énumérer toutes les personnes
mais comme j'aime beaucoup tout le monde
moi je me suis pas arrêté mais il y des
gens qui faisaient pas partie des
missions j'avais j'ai pas vraiment tout
le monde a changé mais ouais ouais
et après j'ai reçu des messages qui me
disait tu as oublié mathieu et agathe
voilà donc du coup j'ai effacé parce
qu'on peut pas modifier la page où tout
s'est passé c'était vraiment un gars à
qui j'avais beaucoup ce que vous
l'utilisiez bat mathieu oui je vais
faire un bisou déjà des valeurs et
agathe je voulais prévenir tout le monde
donc même tous les journaux voilà qui
écrivent des lieux sans savoir que c'est
ma vie si je dis oui et je voulais juste
dire que j'avais pas de problème avec
elle voilà on n'est pas folle coquine
mais on n'a aucun problème ensemble on a
juste moins d'affinités que je peux
avoir avec d'autres personnes
d'accord mais j'ai rien contre elle et
aircal arrêt contre omar et justesse que
maxime guinea celui qui vous a le plus
manqué qui coule non non non ah ouais le
cachons j'accepte en fait même un vote
mais vous manquez pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur si vous êtes le chantier c'est
vous
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'elle
n'avait pas d'argent mais je sais moi
qu'ils appellent tous à l'eau non merci
mais ça me fait très plaisir